like many veterans this last week has
been one that has seen me struggle
through anger and grief
and rage
the feeling abandonment
of not just a country
but the sacrifice
that my friends made
i've been to funerals from poole to
dunblane
i've watched
good men go into the earth
taking with them a part of me and a part
of all of us
and this week has torn open some of
those wounds
left them raw
left us all hurting
and i know it's not just soldiers
i know aid workers and diplomats who
feel the same
i know journalists
who've been the
witnesses
to our country
in its heroic effort
to save people
from the most horrific fates
i know that we've all been struggling
and if this recall has done one thing
let me tell you now mr speaker it's
achieved one thing already
i've spoken to the health secretary
he's already made a commitment
to do more
for veterans mental health
this isn't just about us
the mission in afghanistan wasn't a
british mission it was a nato mission
it was a recognition that globalization
has changed us all
the phone calls that i am still
receiving the text messages that i've
been answering
as i've been waiting
putting people in touch
with our people in afghanistan reminds
us
that we are connected we are connected
still today
and afghanistan is not a far country
about which we know little
it is part of the main
that connection links us also
to our european partners
to our european neighbors
and to our international friends
and so it is
with great sadness that i now criticize
one of them
because i was never prouder than when i
was decorated by the 82nd airborne after
the capture of musa kala
it was a huge privilege
a huge privilege to be recognized by
such an extraordinary unit in combat
to see their commander-in-chief
call into question the courage of men i
fought with
to claim that they ran
it's shameful
those who have never fought for the
colours they fly should be careful about
criticizing those who have
because what we've done
in these last few days
is we've demonstrated that it's not
armies that win wars
armies can get tactical victories and
operational victories that can hold a
line
they can just about
make room for peace make room for people
like us
to talk
to compromise to listen
it's nations that make war
nations endure
nations mobilize and muster
nations
determine
and have patience
and here we've demonstrated
sadly
that we
the west
the united kingdom
does not
now this is a harsh lesson for all of us
and if we're not careful it could be a
very very difficult lesson for our
allies
but it doesn't need to be
we can set out a vision
clearly articulated
for reinvigorating our european nato
partners to make sure that we are not
dependent
on a single ally
on the decision of a single leader
but that we can work together
with japan and australia with france and
germany
with partners large and small
and make sure that we hold the line
together
because we know that patience wins
we know it because we have achieved it
we know it because we have delivered it
the cold war was won
with patience
cyprus is at peace with patience
south korea
with more than 10 times the number of
troops that us that america had in
afghanistan
is prosperous through patience
so let's stop talking
about forever wars
let's recognize
that forever peace is bought
not cheaply
but hard
through determination
and the will to endure
and that the tragedy of afghanistan
is that we're swapping
that patient achievement
for a second fire
and a second war
now we need to turn our attention
to those who are in desperate need
supporting the unhcr the world food
programme and so many other
organizations
who can do so much for people in the
region
yes supporting refugees of course i
support refugees though i'm not going to
get into the political auction
of
numbers we just need to get people out
so i leave with one image
in the year that i was privileged to be
the advisor to the governor of helmand
we opened girls schools
and the joy it gave parents
to see their little girls going to
school was extraordinary and i didn't
understand it until i took my own
daughter to school
about a year ago
there was a lot of crying
when she first went in
but i got over it and
[Laughter]
it went okay
and i would love to see
that continue
but there is a second image i must leave
you with
and it is a harder one
but i'm afraid it is one that i think we
must all remember
leave away
and i wonder if you could say a bit more
about that second image
i'm very grateful to my friend who was
watching the clock
more than me
the second image is one
that the forever war that has just
reignited
could lead to
it is the image of a man
whose name i never knew
carrying a child
who had died
hours earlier
carrying this child
into our firebase
and begging for help
now there was nothing we could do
it was
over
because mr speaker this is what defeat
looks like
it's when you no longer have the choice
after how to help
this doesn't need to be defeat
but at the moment damn well feels like
it davey
[Applause]